bonjour today's video is kindly
sponsored by babble the world's number
one best-selling language learning app
hey 42 here you're probably familiar
with the story of the pied piper of
hamlin it's one of those timeless tales
that's been told and retold for
centuries legendary german author goethe
wrote a famous poem about it as did
english poet robert browning and perhaps
the best known version of the story was
written by the most renowned purveyors
of fairy tales in history
the brothers grimm you may not know it
but hamlin is actually a real place a
small town in lower saxony germany as
you can probably imagine the town likes
to play up its fairytale link and it
attracts tens of thousands of tourists
each year off the back of it but this is
where things get a little strange
hamlin is an old town
first settled way back in the 8th
century if you were to take a trip there
today and delve into the town's
extensive archives
you might stumble across an entry
written over 600 years ago in 1384.
it's only short just nine words long
but those nine words
speak volumes
it is over 100 years since our children
left
you see the pied piper of hamlin isn't
like most fairy tales carefully
constructed to teach children about the
real world
in fact
it isn't really a fairy tale at all
it's based on real events
disturbing ones with over 10 million
subscribers worldwide and content
updated daily babble is top of the list
for anyone who's looking to learn a new
language and it's easy to see why i have
a few distant relatives in france who
i'd like to know a little bit better but
they don't speak much english and it
would be really nice if i could converse
a little easier with them so
my new year's resolution this year is to
learn to speak french with babel
babel is packed full of great learning
content and it's all designed by real
life language experts in order to get
you learning with real life situations
and dialogue it offers 10 minute lessons
that are proven to get you speaking in a
new language in just three weeks babel
also has podcasts stories and games to
completely immerse yourself in the
language of your choice
babble is great because it works but
don't just take my word for it
university studies have actually shown
that just 15 hours of babble are
equivalent to a full semester of college
spanish
so this year why don't you make a new
year's resolution you can actually stick
to and feel good about yourself at the
same time by learning a new language
with babel
if you sign up to babel today you can
get 65
off and babel offers a 20-day money-back
guarantee so you've got nothing to lose
click the link in the description to
start learning a new language today of
war airborne chance
just in case you aren't familiar with
the original fairy tale it goes
something like this
hamlin's suffering from a rat problem
when a chapping colorful clothes the
pied piper turns up claiming to be the
world's best dressed rat catcher
keen to be rid of the town's whiskery
scourge the mayor of hamlin agrees to
pay a large sum of money to this
stranger for his services
unfortunately the pied piper isn't much
of a businessman because instead of
writing up a contract or asking for a
down payment he just gets to work that
work is fairly unorthodox too he doesn't
reach for the warfarin or set up some
traps
no the pied piper pulls out his flute
and begins to play
no doubt that raises a few eyebrows
amongst the people of hamlin but to
their amazement
thousands of rats suddenly begin to
emerge from their hiding places
the piper then leads them down to the
river where they promptly drown
themselves
but this is where the pied piper's lack
of paperwork comes back to bite him on
his colourful arse because hamlin's
mayor refuses to pay up to exact his
revenge the piper begins playing once
more only this time it's the children
who follow him out of the town exactly
what happens next depends on which
version of the story you read but most
involve the children reaching some kind
of sticky end
or disappearing
never to be seen again the evidence that
these events or at least something like
them really did take place in hamlin
more than 700 years ago is compelling
along with that eerie entry in the
town's ledger i just mentioned
eyewitness accounts appear in several
surviving texts from the 14th and 15th
centuries the events were also depicted
in a stained glass window that was
installed in the town church somewhere
around 1300 presumably as a grim
reminder of the tragic event that had
taken place a few years earlier
then there's the inscription that can be
found carved into the facade of one of
hamlin's oldest buildings fittingly
known as the pied piper's house
carved about 500 years ago it reads
a.d 1284 on the 26th of june the day of
saints john and saint paul
130 children born in hamlin were led out
of the town by a piper wearing
multi-coloured clothes
after passing the cavalry near the
coppenberg
they disappeared forever
there's enough here to convince most
historians that some kind of tragedy
befell the children of hamlin all those
years ago
but what exactly that tragedy was is the
subject of some debate
and for obvious reasons i mean it's safe
to say we can't take the story of the
pied piper entirely at face value for
one thing rats aren't known to be
susceptible to flute-based mind control
neither are children for that matter
most people who've studied the origins
of the story believe it grew out of a
real event that's slowly been
embellished over the centuries through a
kind of multi-generational game of
chinese whispers meaning something
terrible
really did happen to the children of
hamlet in 1284
and the story of the pied piper that we
know today has survived as a kind of
folk memory of that tragedy as for what
really happened well
there are several interesting theories
the first is that hamlin's children were
killed in a massive accident of some
kind a few different options have been
suggested some people believe the
children were drowned in a nearby river
after the collapse of a bridge
others suspect a landslide might have
been to blame if the accident theory's
true the pied piper himself probably
never existed and was instead added to
the story later to represent the figure
of death
leading the children out of this world
and into the next the accident
hypothesis is certainly plausible
but it does seem a little unlikely that
so many children 130 according to the
plaque could have been killed in a
single event like that and if they were
no records survive that mentioned the
incident explicitly one theory that's
been fairly popular over the years is
that the black death was to blame for
the loss of the hamline's children who
were led away from the town in order to
stop the terrible disease from spreading
you can see why people have favored this
one
since rats are central to both the story
of the pied piper and the history of the
black death although if you haven't seen
my video on why rats probably weren't to
blame for the black death i recommend
you give it a try whilst it looks pretty
good on paper this theory is easy to
rule out first of all rats didn't appear
in the story of the pied piper of hamlin
at all until the mid-1500s they're just
one of the many embellishments added to
the tale over the centuries
and second the dates don't work the loss
of hamlin's children in 1284 predates
the arrival of the bubonic plague in
europe by more than 60 years
proponents of the black death theory
have suggested hamlin might have been
the site of an early plague outbreak but
that's just a case of trying to make the
facts fit the theory rather than basing
the theory on the facts not only is it
pretty unlikely that 130 cases of
bubonic plague would have randomly
popped up in a small town in germany and
then gone away for 60 years
it's even more unlikely that only
children would have been affected
one of the more enticing theories about
the disappearance of the children of
hamlin might already be familiar to you
if you've been following the channel for
a while some people have postulated that
the children were struck down by an
outbreak of dancing mania a kind of mass
psychogenic illness that's poorly
understood even to this day during
dancing manias hundreds or even
thousands of people would suddenly start
to dance uncontrollably sometimes doing
so for days on end until they dropped
dead from exhaustion i did a whole video
on this incredibly weird phenomenon a
while back so i won't go into too much
detail here on the specifics but both
the location and the timelines do seem
to fit at least approximately most of
europe's dancing manias occurred between
the 14th and 17th centuries in england
germany and the netherlands and there
are a few examples where only children
were involved including one that took
place just a couple of hundred miles
from hamlin
whether or not that's just a coincidence
is impossible to say a dancing mania
might explain where the pied piper comes
into things as well a piper could
conceivably have triggered a dancing
mania outbreak or perhaps the figure was
added to the story in retrospect in an
attempt to try and rationalize the fact
that 130 children just got up and
started dancing for no reason whilst
there's something quite compelling about
this theory it does come with its
downsides dancing mania didn't tend to
kill all of those that took part in fact
some historians dispute the idea that
they were ever actually fatal at all so
presumably if an outbreak of
uncontrollable dancing was the kernel of
truth at the center of the pied piper
story
plenty of children involved would have
lived to tell the tale if that were the
case it doesn't really fit with either
the town ledger entry or the inscription
on the pied piper's house both of which
imply the missing children were gone for
good english writer william manchester
had his own colourful theory about the
origins of the story
suggesting that the pied piper was a
psychopathic child molester he preyed on
the children of hamline for his own
sexual gratification
which sounds pretty extreme but it
certainly more plausible than one of the
other common explanations
aliens some historians okay probably not
historians believe the pied piper was
actually a being from another world who
charmed the children of hamelin using a
high-tech alien device that the locals
thought looked a bit like a flute
i'm going to go ahead and put this one
down as a long shot actually it's fair
to say that all the theories i've
covered so far are pretty speculative
there isn't really enough evidence to
confidently confirm or rule out most of
them
but the next one which incidentally is
favored by the majority of historians
these days
is slightly different and whilst it's a
little less dramatic than pandemics or
pedos
it's still pretty intriguing in its own
way
the world was a very different place
back when the children of hamelin went
missing
if you fly over western europe in an
airplane today the vast majority of what
you can see is either some kind of
settlement or farmland
the world as we humans have made it
but 700 years ago the global population
was just five percent of what it is
today and the spaces in between
inhabited areas were much bigger it was
forests not farms that dominated the
landscape
that meant anybody wishing to go and
claim new territory first needed to
clear it off of trees and undergrowth no
small task considering the cutting edge
technology in
well
cutting edges consisted of hand axes and
saws at the time
clearing large waves of dense forest
with this limited arsenal was hard work
and it took a lot of dedicated manpower
according to professor jurgen udolph a
former linguistics professor at the
university of gottingen that's the same
university where the brothers grimm once
taught by the way the children of
hamelin were simply hired on mass by
landowners from the east to clear
forests and build new towns villages and
estates you might be wondering why
anyone would hire kids for this kind of
hard labor and that's a fair question
it might just be that the world children
is being used pretty liberally here we
all know older people who still consider
us to be children no matter how often we
tell them that we're proper newspaper
reading tax paying grown-ups these days
plus most landowners tended to
specifically target younger people since
they were typically healthier and less
bothered about upping sticks and moving
somewhere new or maybe the use of the
word children was simply meant to refer
to the citizens of hamline in general
either way this theory makes a lot of
sense particularly in a historical
context a large wave of land south of
the baltic sea in what is now poland
became available for german colonisation
in the 13th century after the danish who
had recently invaded were defeated in
the battle of born hovered in 1227. as a
result there was plenty of eastwood
immigration going on at the time as
wealthy landowners looked to claim the
new territory
to aid in their expansion efforts many
employed what were known as locators
men who would go from town to town
attempting to recruit able-bodied
individuals to help them with all the
grunt work interestingly enough locators
often wore brightly coloured coats and
funny hats that weren't a million miles
away from the garments to pied piper is
usually depicted as wearing one such
locator may well have ended up in hamlin
and after selling the dream of a new
life and riches to the east left with a
large number of the town's younger
denizens to add a little more weight to
this theory several towns and villages
with various versions of the name hamlin
appeared to the east around this time
hinting that widespread emigration very
likely did take place german names that
were once common in hamlin also crop up
with surprising frequency in some parts
of poland even to this day having said
all that there's still no way to know
for sure if some kind of mass emigration
was the tragic event that morphed into
the story of the pied piper of hamline
it seems to fit in many ways but then
the evidence is still very much
circumstantial hamlin is just one of
hundreds of towns that would have been
affected by eastwood immigration at the
time so it's difficult to see why this
particular example would have spread
across the globe in the form of a folk
memory in quite the way it has
so was the pied piper a fictional
embodiment of death in the face of some
centuries-old tragedy
a particularly skillful headhunter in a
fancy coat or one of history's scariest
child molesters
i'll leave that up to you
thanks for watching